RUSSIA IS USING ITS WORDS AND
ITS ACTIONS TO SEND A WARNING TO
THE U.S. TONIGHT.
MOSCOW HAS SENT A WARSHIP TO
CUBA AND SAID THE U.S. WEAPONS
BUILDUP IN EUROPE COULD SPARK A
REPEAT OF ONE OF THE MOST
DANGEROUS CONFLICTS OF THE
COLD WAR.
NATIONAL SECURITY CORRESPONDENT
JENNIFER GRIFFIN HAS THE STORY
TONIGHT FROM THE PENTAGON.
>> THE NEW STATE-OF-THE-ART
RUSSIAN WARSHIP RECEIVED A WARM
WELCOME AFTER PULLING INTO
HAVANA HARBOR JUST 90 MILES FROM
FLORIDA, OCCUPYING A BIRTH WHICH
UNTIL A RECENT TRAVEL BAN WAS
FILLED BY AMERICAN TOURIST
CRUISE SHIPS.
>> THIS IS A CLEAR SHOW OF FORCE
BY RUSSIA.
>> RUSSIA'S DEPUTY FOREIGN
MINISTER WARNED OF A NEW
CUBAN MISSILE CRISIS IF THE U.S.
CHOOSES TO DEPLOY MISSILES BACK
TO EUROPE AFTER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION SAID IT PLANS TO
PULL OUT OF A LANDMARK NUCLEAR
ARMS TREATY.
"WE COULD FIND OURSELVES IN A
SITUATION WHERE WE HAVE A ROCKET
CRISIS NOT JUST CLOSE TO THE
CRISIS OF THE 1980s BUT CLOSE
TO THE CARIBBEAN CRISIS."
>> THE RUSSIANS ARE LAUNCHING A
PROPAGANDA CAMPAIGN AT THIS TIME
CLAIMING THAT THE UNITED STATES
IS ACTING IN A PROVOCATIVE
FASHION WHICH IS NOT TRUE.
>> THE ARRIVAL IN HAVANA NOT AS
MENACING AS THIS ENCOUNTER WEEKS
AGO IN THE WESTERN PACIFIC WHEN
A RUSSIAN DESTROYER HARASSED OF
THE USS OF CHANCELLORSVILLE
NEARLY COLLIDE AND, FORCING THE
AMERICAN WARSHIP TO ALTER
COURSE.
EARLIER THIS MONTH, MOSCOW SAID
ONE OF ITS FIGHTER JETS
INTERCEPTED A U.S. B-52 BOMBER
IN THE BLACK SEA, ONE OF MANY
INCREASINGLY AGGRESSIVE
ENCOUNTERS BETWEEN THE TWO
COLD WAR FOES.
BACK IN HAVANA, THE ARRIVAL OF
THE ADMIRAL GORSHKOV.
A 10,000 NATO TROOP WAR GAME
EXERCISE ON RUSSIAN'S DOORSTEP
INVOLVING 50 ALLIED WARSHIPS IN
THE PENTAGON ANNOUNCES PLANS TO
ADD NEW LOW YIELD NUCLEAR
WEAPONS TO BALLISTIC MISSILE
SUBMARINES, A RESPONSE TO
RUSSIA'S THREAT TO USE LIMITED
NUCLEAR WEAPONS ON THE
BATTLEFIELD.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S NEW ACTING
DEFENSE SECRETARY FLEW TO NATO
HEADQUARTERS TODAY AND IS THE